I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense there's a whole book so yeah are
there a whole 30 is like so easy for
people to follow because it's so black
or white I'm like here's what you do for
30 days food freedom is like okay now
here's how you take what you've learned
on the whole 30 and turn it into a diet
that works for you your own kind of
perfect plan and that's a lot harder
people still kind of want to be told
what to do like well okay but in my food
freedom is it okay if I do this is it
okay if I have that if I'm gonna eat
sugar and I food freedom what kind
should I eat and the answer is like
whichever one you want whatever you
decide is worth it so the book really
provides like a framework for helping
you figure out what's worth it and what
you really want and how to create this
diet for you in a way that doesn't that
isn't me telling you what to eat because
that's not food freedom so I try to
provide as much guide work as I can
we talked about in the moment success
strategies a lot of times we have to
distance ourself from the immediate
temptation of that food you know you get
served cookie or a glass of wine oh
there are a number of strategies you can
do you can take a deep breath
like honestly we can get into this fight
or flight panic reflex when we see a
tempting food especially if we've had
this like lifetime of unhealthy habits
and association with this food so just
sitting and taking a deep breath can
help putting the food in a timeout
saying to yourself like okay if I still
want it in five minutes then I'll eat it
but I'm not gonna make and like
irrational in the moment decision where
sort of my brain is overriding what I
really want and so that's a success
strategy imagining what the outcome is
gonna feel like an hour after you eat it
because eating something that provides
instant gratification but makes you feel
like crap for the next 24 hours I'm not
really a treat yeah I don't know that's
for me the biggest thing yeah yeah
when I eat something that makes me I
mean like sure it can taste good sugar
always tastes good yeah sugar sugar yeah
I say yeah but when I feel like bloated
like I have a food baby I'm like I just
want to go to sleep and wake up and have
it be gone because I feel just feels so
uncomfortable not worth it not me
exactly but yeah there's that there's
that downside and then there are some
long-term kind of things that you can do
you know when you think about things
like what what's most likely to throw
you off your healthy eating game
holidays vacations stressful events and
so I provide strategies for kind of how
to navigate those in a way that my
allows you to make the most of your
vacation like it's not that fun to be on
vacation and feel like crap because
you've eaten and drank a bunch of stuff
that you know isn't serving you so well
how can people learn how to take care of
themselves best like what are what are
what are some of the best ways to be
able to go on vacation and not fall
apart yeah I mean I go on bake look I
was on vacation for the 45 of 90 days at
the beginning of the year like I mean
yeah and I stay on the programs so like
what how do people do it that I like I
really like giving people small wins so
it's like if you are thinking about
taking a mini trip or even just take
even just practice it like on a weekend
where you have a special event where
you're very conscientiously and
deliberate yet deliberately asking
yourself like is this a special food is
it gonna mess me up if it is how is it
gonna mess me up even the degree that
it's gonna mess me up gonna make it
worth it in the long run like if you're
on vacation
on a beach and you want to just like
feel your best and have good energy and
be able to like take you know take
advantage of the situation you're in
you're not gonna want to eat something
that has you out like a light by 11 a.m.
or has you feeling super bloated or like
not comfortable in your skin so thinking
about that ahead of time and really like
conscientiously having those moments
where you're like okay I know I'm in
Mexico I know it's a margarita but it's
11:00 in the morning and I'm not a good
day drinker yeah isn't gonna serve me
and saying no and passing out there's
always like if there's a ferry there's
that look like when I go on vacation I'm
like okay I know how to stay away from
all of the the dairy and the gluten and
the grains and the beans like that's yet
to me that's easy right some people
don't some people literally don't know
that garbanzo is a bean yeah it's not
even in their realm of consciousness or
awareness right and they go and they
have you know you know a fro like a
mixed drink there's you how many people
think that tonic is water ya know right
I know I know
sharpen up if ya give a [ __ ] about
yourself you have to understand food and
for me if you can't if you the way that
you're gonna learn how to operate in the
real world or out in a restaurant or on
vacation is you don't know how to cook
yeah
yeah I mean you don't know how to cook
you don't know how it's made
yeah food freedom always starts with a
reset whether it's a whole thirty reset
or a vegan reset if you're a vegan like
there there has to be that reset because
until you get to a place where you feel
like your cravings are under control
your blood Sugar's that are regulated
your hormones are better balanced your
digestion isn't acting up as much your
immune system is calling like until you
get to that place where you get that
good baseline where you feel so good
you're not gonna have anything to
measure it from right see it's really
hard to dump someone into a vacation
eating whatever they've been eating and
be like okay now try to moderate that
yes advice like just everything in
moderation right but you know probably
not going on vacation wondering how
they're going to stay on a program where
I haven't been on a program than right
starting it right the point is it's like
how can they go to a restaurant and look
at a menu and go I got this yeah because
for me I'm going okay I'm gonna have a
fish I'm gonna have vegetables I'm gonna
ask you know I'm gonna say you know can
they if I'm gonna know what says sauteed
versus roasted yeah vs. fried yeah I
know I know when a fish says sauteed
versus grilled I know what that means
like I know that they pretty much put
some kind of oil or fat on every protein
as before they hand it out to you right
whether it's oil or butter or something
like that they're gonna or sauces yeah
always asking for that on the side but
you have to actually cook at home to
know that stuff you can't you can't go
out to breakfast and be like oh I you
know I I didn't know that bacon had this
senator is dairy in the eggs yeah I
didn't know there was yeah I didn't know
they mixed it with milk when they make
the scrambled egg sir this is why you do
a whole three you do a whole 30 because
the program structure forces you to ask
those kinds of questions to make it
yourself and that eggs this morning oh
is it
dairy in the eggs can I get shelled eggs
instead yeah and you're cooking at home
in the program so many people have said
the whole 30 taught me how to cook and
that's a huge benefit of the program so
yes it starts with the whole 30 and then
once you reach that baseline now you
have a new foundation to go on vacation
and say yeah okay like can I finish this
vacation feeling as good as I did when I
started
you